tonight there is a push to get more
people who are
over the age of 65 vaccinated this comes
as a lot of appointments are just not
being filled
joe mueller is live at the convention
center tonight with an update for us joe
well today we learned that the health uh
state health officials are working to
get more of these appointments that are
not being filled
filled and actually today was a very
busy day but it's now slowed down here
at the las vegas convention center the
parking lot just an hour ago was very
full but
now it is completely empty now earlier
today during a zoom meeting with state
health officials this afternoon
there was discussion that only 63
percent of people over the age of 65
have received the vaccine
they want between 70 and 80 percent of
the age group to be vaccinated
last week the jansen or johnson and
johnson vaccine arrived to southern
nevada
people are now able to choose which
vaccine they want at a certain location
such as the convention center and
catchment center
now frank balote who we spoke with
earlier today says he was given the
option when he showed up for a shot
depending on what you were in for your
first or second dose
but you had the choice when you walked
in they had the jansen or
kaiser depending which one you chose
what lane you took
he ended up getting the advisor today
now according to state health officials
we could see a pause and distribution of
the jansen vaccine in coming weeks but
locations will continue to have the
advisor
and modern vaccines now back out here
live if you don't have access to
internet
you can also call make an appointment
that number is 1-800-401-0946 that phone
line is open from 8
00 a.m until 8 p.m and just a short time
ago on the health district's website
they did post more eligibility
that's going to be for transportation
workers and staff such as buses
lyft and uber will have much more on
that coming up here at six o'clock
reporting live here at the convention
center joe mullen 8 news